wanna make this perfectly clear at the
beginning of this review because there
could be some people see the trailers
like do I have to know wrestling to get
into this movie no you do not have to be
a wrestling fanatic or know anything
about wrestling to enjoy this movie at
all I just want to clarify that at the
beginning that's important stuff now you
know
[Music]
finding with my family so fighting with
my family is the true story of WWE
Superstar Paige now this is the story of
how she became paid this has gotta be it
look this is the surprise of the year
you're still in its infancy that
probably doesn't mean much I really got
to say this movie surprised me like on
every level surprised me but like I said
before this isn't a wrestling movie it's
an underdog story it's a biopic underdog
story of this girl from this small town
who doesn't really have a real shot at
becoming a superstar in the WWE when she
gets that chance man she's gonna go
after it but everyone in this movie is
great like everybody is great Nick Frost
and Lena Headey or Headey I never know
as her parents her brother her main star
Florence Pugh she was fantastic in this
movie she crushed it this movie doesn't
work if she doesn't work and she totally
worked
Vince Vaughn was great in this movie mr.
Wayne the rock Johnson is in it he's
funny he's on the poster as this
prominent figure I get why he's on the
poster cuz Dwayne the rock Johnson he
sells tickets it's not like he's in the
forefront of this movie it sound like
he's the one training her Vince Vaughn
plays the coach this movie just had
everything I wanted a movie like this to
have great characters snappy dialogue it
has heart it's about family but it also
has a lot of humor like more humor than
I thought this movie would have that's
why I had to look into who wrote this
movie who directed a holy shet it's
Stephen Merchant it makes more sense now
but I hadn't laughed this hard in a
movie in a very long time and the
important thing and I really want to
stress this important thing the humor to
me never compromised the drama when a
dramatic moment was happening the drama
it marinates win those really human
moments of humor come up is they happen
cuz her and her family where she comes
from they're really obscure people not
putting them down or anything that
they're unique I love that because
that's a pocket that's a zone that a lot
of movies aim for and they miss a lot of
movies interject humor where there
should be drama it's like you just
killed the drama this movie understands
first and foremost is a character movie
it is a drama but let's make people
laugh if we can and it made me laugh a
lot and also it made me well up a lot by
the end of this movie my god like you
know allergy season is crazy
is mad pollen in the winter beyond us a
couple days ago I did have a massive
allergy attack it was terrible it was
when all the snow melted something
happened maybe I'm allergic to ice it's
just a really it's an inspiring move
in inspiring entertaining and even funny
movie about an underdog striving for
their goal in life the dynamic between
her and her brother - that [ __ ] is heavy
we can all take something away from this
movie we can all learn from this movie
and a big lesson in this movie is that
we're not entitled to anything life does
not owe you greatness it doesn't owe you
Fame it doesn't owe you success no it
was just it was a heavy movie which is
unusual for a movie that made me laugh
this much I just didn't expect it what
can I say it's an inspiring story about
heart dreams family hope relating to
human beings expectation managing them
pride doubts into all of it movie hit me
on so many levels this is movie than
anybody anybody can watch appreciate and
enjoy and I will say fighting with my
family is awesome tacular
second one and two reviews this is a
good weekend granted as always with
biopics I don't know where the fantasy
ends and the reality begins true they
took a liberties here and they're sure
they might have taken a lot of Liberty
don't know all I know is this is a great
movie we're still fighting with my
family have you seen it what do you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]